[Music]
Jayla spanish single live the Latin
Billboard Awards last night Anika thank
you looks good whoa this is hot and by
the way the lyrics of that song may be
influenced by her man
a rod I was exclusively on set for J
Lo's new and very symbolic music -
Thomas K your thing the title of the
song Ella neo means the ring
so is this JLo secret message - a rod
that he said I put a ring on it of
course everyone's gonna ask you is there
a ring or is on a ring are we having a
ring it's kind of like if you want me in
your life you have to give me the
respect and place in your life that I
deserve and I think sometimes is a
symbol of that there's hidden references
to a-rod in the lyrics like that's how
we do it from the Bronx and you're a 13
out of 10 when we're in bed 13 of course
is the number on a Ron's Jersey there
are a few references listen I didn't
write the song
I played it for Alex and I was like are
you cool with this I think it's kind of
funny he's like yeah I'm totally cool
with it
listen I don't think he's just okay with
it he wants to be in it because he
posted instagrams right here's like when
is she gonna come in I know
are you auditioned he loves to dance if
you catch him like in the corner
sometimes he'll like be doing like PG
was exclusive on set at the Ellen neon
music video it took two days to shoot
JLo had seven costume changes looking at
the finished product it's clear
Jennifer's dedicated to her work no
surprise she's just as committed to her
relationship with a-rod we make the
effort and it and it is you know II
would say maybe was like you better say
thank you like you better say thank you
I'm flying in he's flying out with fly
it's it's a lot to keep up with each
other but you know when there's a will
there's a way and we love being together
and so we make every possible effort to
do that whenever we have a three minute
and that's you know
[Music]
[Applause]